okay thanks and there hi everyone yeah I
said that when we talk about survival
analysis and how we're using it entails
to understand lifetime value and
customer attention so just a brief
outline of the talk I'm going to
introduce myself tell you a little bit
about tails and who they are if you
haven't heard of us and then talk about
meta the lifetime value and retention
and then go on to the survival analysis
bit and how we're using this to model
all of these things cool so hi this is
me obviously and I before being a data
scientist that tails calm I was a
mathematician I did my undergrad at York
I did my PhD at Bristol I didn't go
straight into data science I was
actually working as an analyst at
department for education for a while
modeling policy spending and
participation impacts and education but
then I got more and more interested in
Python and what you could do with the
language and along with data got into
data science doing a si internship and
I've been at tails for the last year and
a half so who is tails comm in fact has
anybody heard of tails excellent who has
a doc couple of people all right tough
crowd so anyway we are a tailor-mades
dog food subscription service so if you
have a dog m and you are at a loss comm
customer every month to your door we
will deliver you a tailor-made dog free
blends which is specific for your dog at
that time and how old they are so we do
this by getting you to fill in an online
consultation with us when you sign up
you tell us all about your dog that
breeds the health conditions the
previous food the flavors they like the
age all of these things go into helping
us understand what dog food it is that
your dog really really needs and we
package that up we send it to your door
with in a bag with your dog's name on it
and really it's for them not for you and
and each month we'll just keep sending
your food as long as you're a customer
and and as your dog ages they need to
change the food changes with that so you
don't have to worry again about what
food you should be feeding your dog we
take care of all of it and so just as in
some numbers then say we currently got
roughly
85,000 customers $85,000 story which is
about one percent of the UK dog
population and which equates to four
million meals a month that we're feeding
which is really exciting and it's twenty
four pounds if you're a customer on
average obviously that varies massively
because dogs vary massively and how much
they need to eat and we also do treat
some wet food and one of the cool things
is because our food is tailor-made we
have a blend algorithm which determines
exactly how much food your dog needs and
all the nutrients and everything to
create the perfect blend so we're
searching roughly a million blends in
real time to generate your food and and
we are growing fast so target is we're
going to have sales exceeding twenty
million this year we currently have 100
employees in total and we also have 25
office dogs so which are very much very
much part of the family we are hiring so
remember this slide when we get to the
end of the talk this is and cool so
customer retention and lifetime value
then so this talk as then it's about
survival analysis and the retention side
of that I guess it could also equally be
about how when you're going into a
techie but not directly data science see
startup is the first data scientist and
how like how you can get some really
great successful data science products
really value driving projects that you
can work on that are really going to get
used and lifetime value has proven to be
one of those things so why do we care
about lifetime value so lifetime value
as a subscription business it tells you
each customer how much but essentially
how much value we think that you're
going to generate for us over the amount
of time that you're going to be feeding
tails so if we have a good understanding
of lifetime value we can use this to
look at product giveaways maybe we have
an offer we will have some free sample
we want people to try things you know we
obviously have to scale the things we
want to give away relative to the value
of the customers that should be tails
because otherwise essentially we're
going to lose money and eventually go
about business and refunds as well so
obviously you know if you've had of our
service and we think you deserve a
refund
how generous we allow ourselves to be
could also you could also use lifetime
value as a metric in that a marketing
spend
it's obviously acquiring customers is
expensive and so it's the case of we
don't mind as much like we can we can
spend afford to spend a little bit more
money acquiring the customers that we
really think you're going to love tails
so you know it's good way to pay a
little spent and also project
prioritization everyone's got a new
feature that they want ads or a book
that they really want to fix but the
amount of time that we should be
spending on all of these things should
be relative to how much actual value we
think that this is going to generate for
the company because if we spend our time
chasing tiny margins and then we're
never going to grow and be successful I
don't know this is all kind of turning
everything thinking about profit but
it's important as well right because
obviously we're here because we like
dogs and we think they deserve a
tailor-made service and so the better
the more successful we can be the more
dogs we can bring into feeding tails and
so the more we can change the world of
pet food so this is really what we're
going for
so our lifetime value model is
essentially built out of three
components which i think is kind of
standard and we sort of the way I built
it each three of these things kind of
works independently and then we
aggregate them together to get the total
value at the end so all we see it's
their retention so how long we think
you're going to be a customer obviously
determines how many how much value we
can get from you your frequency how many
orders we think you're going to get we'd
like you to order every month but
obviously some people will pause or
delay or move their orders around so
this stuff is taken into account and
order value so the bigger your dog the
more stuff you buy you know the base
essentially the higher your order value
and again this is a big part of your
lifetime value overall so today I'm just
going to talk a little bit about the
analysis that we're doing for the
retention side of it and so I guess a
lot of retention talks that you see and
a lot of companies out there that help
you don't you understand customer
retention all seem to be based around
like a very like classification view for
attention right you're like looking at
the probe you know the chance of
somebody making it to the next order or
trying to identify people that aren't
going to
a free trial things like this and these
are all really useful and we also have
models like this working in tails but
but don't really tell us you know it's
very much like the binary outcome of our
you can order how are you not next month
isn't really in the Katif of how long we
think you're going to be a customer
which is really what we care about with
lifetime value so what we need is a more
like regression based approach
essentially which we're survival
analysis comes in so what is it okay
well let's get with a quick motivation
and the question that sometimes I do get
asked that tails as well it's like okay
well what is the average description
when it's like how long the people
customers are tails and so okay let's
take say we have nine Pepsi and then
these bars are tracking their average
subscription lengths the green bars and
the pets that are still active and the
red bars are their pets that are no
longer active customers are tails so you
say what's the average subscription
length it's like well well if I just
take the average of all of these patents
you're like well that's not really fair
because of what these people are still
active and if I do this again next month
I'm going to get a totally different
answer because it's a moving target I'm
essentially trying to look at so I'm
like okay well if I just ignore the
active people and just take the inactive
people and look at the average of that
you're like well no not really because
again like some people become inactive
and that will change also you're
massively biasing your dataset so the
people who've already cancelled so
neither way of taking the
straightforward out which really gives
you what you want and the reason for
this is because we've got sense of data
where we have data where we haven't
actually observed the endpoint that
we're trying to measure yet so
essentially taking an average like this
is never really going to be a sensible
thing to do so we need survival analysis
so try and overcome this problem and
this is kind of a study of estimating
the time to an event for a particular
population when you may not have all you
know seen all the events happen it's all
your data points so where is it used in
fact it's a really quite an old idea in
statistics and it's used quite a lot so
for example in medical statistics not a
very cheery example to start with but
and if you're looking at survival rates
after cancer and the probability that
people are surviving five ten years
is all survival analysis that she used
to do this if you're buying life
insurance essentially your premium is
determined on how long the actuaries
think that you've got to live and so
therefore how much they can afford to
sell you life insurance for but going
back to what we care about is our
customers and our dogs and what we're
looking at is from when customers have
signed up and started and moved off
their free trial on to pay for orders
how long do we think they're going to be
open to receiving more tails food which
obviously then goes into the lifetime
value side of it so I just start with a
few definitions so a small maxi slide
and so we'll take care capital t we'll
take this be the time to a subscription
end for air customer so and this so it's
obviously greater than zero but it could
be infinite if the customer never turns
and the quantity that we care about and
the thing that's going to help us
understand lifetime value is the
probability that the customer hasn't
churned at any day T into the future and
this is their a non decreasing function
okay because sorry non increasing
function and but what we so we have the
overall probability but what's also
important here is and what's going to
happen on each infinitesimal day we
define this by the hazard function which
is the probability that on any given day
T that this is the day that the customer
turns not one day before not one day
afterwards and actually these two things
I mean as you expect are related but it
was just like a little bit of elementary
probability you can show that
essentially the survival function is
expressed in terms of the hazard
function in a relatively simple way and
so far I've not really told you anything
about what has this function might look
like or survival function this kind of
holds for any expression or
interpretation of survival function
hazard function today so you know this
is also quite cool nice general formula
so a few package options so I've been
mostly doing this in Python
so in Python you've got two main package
Upson's you've got lifelines and
psychics of a survival
so lifelines is kind of a longer
standing package it's very very
lightweight and both of these are based
on their scikit-learn so you can use
them how you'd use any scikit-learn
package and put it in pipelines and
stuff like that and but yeah lifelines
again it's got basically one job which
is to do survival analysis so it's very
very lightweight and so it's quite quick
just start using it and but it and it's
got really nice visualizations of
everything that's going on the only
thing is that it only really covers
linear in models for air survive
analysis so if you want something a
little bit you know more robust yeah
yeah so that's in that's that's what I'm
using here and so yeah but it's a it's a
good easy one to get started with and if
any of you were at PyCon last year and
sebastian Postel gave a talk on his PhD
projects which was making psychic
survival which is a really good
extension to lifelines and this again
it's you know built on the whole
scikit-learn infrastructure and and it's
got a lot more options of linear and
nonlinear models that you can use and so
you can do a lot more detailed analysis
in there as well so yeah two really good
options and there's also our because
again it's a long-standing technique in
statistics so there's actually quite a
lot of our packages that do both linear
and like ensemble based methods for
looking at survival analysis and there's
also a lot of tutorials and lectures on
the subjects and a lot of these tend to
follow and a dataset and a package in
our so it's like a good way to learn a
theory maybe if you're used to using off
personally like I learnt Python before
our and that's kind of where my
preferences so I find switching to our I
work at it's like a little bit slower to
train and everything like that and and
also our stack at tales this Python base
so about it's obviously biased to what I
use there but yeah there's quite a lot
of options out there for doing this kind
of stuff
okay
so how do we do the modeling so as I
said before we want to what we care
about is this quantity s of T the
survival function for a customer and the
probability that they're still a
customer at day T and and we can't in
practice just know this function because
of our sense of data so instead what you
can do to estimate it is use a
kaplan-meier estimate of the function
which was essentially built up like it's
a product of its kind of yeah
essentially products of the ratio of the
pets that have been allowed to get to
that point I think we've had enough data
on them that they've reached 80 and then
a ratio of the total that there were and
the ones that are turned on that day and
so you know it built up basically as a
step function which gets you don't let's
get into the testing the smaller the
more data that you have and and again
like just using my phone's package it's
pretty simple just to drop this in so
here it's just like god there's loops a
for a few of our promo groups that we
have let's look at what the survival
curves look like and pop them so when we
run this we get a graph that looks like
this and there you can see I've got some
confidence intervals here so it's like
getting a good approximation of where
the true survival curve would be in in
this data so first off now we can
finally answer the question what is an
average subscription length for a
customer so to do this we're essentially
taking the median time the customer is
expected to be to survive until so
essentially reading off where we're 50%
on the probability they're still a
customer and this tells us the expected
number of days they're you in this
survival curve we think you're going to
be there and what you can also see is
there's quite a big difference between
all these curves because as it turns out
how you find us a tails and how you
become a customer gives us quite a lot
of information about how much we think
that you're joining tails because you
really really love the service and you
know you've thought hard and this is
like the best food for your dog and
joining it because you know you read
about it in a magazine you might have a
different you know
the tails when he joins and so things
like this we can see really really
impact our expectation of how long do we
think you're going to be a customer
which in turn influences your lifetime
value so what we can do is an extension
to this then is essentially build a
regression model where we're trying to
estimate your survival function based on
all of the factors that we know about
you so the model that is chosen one of
the ones one of the options and I think
probably the most well used still and is
the Cox proportional hazards model and
so if we remember our survival function
as expressed in terms of our has a
function like this the cop support in
the house of model says and gives like
this expression or R has a function and
so why is it called proportional hazards
is because for each two pets for like
any two pets at a given point in time
the ratio of their hazards is constant
because all of the information in how
there has the changes over time is
encoded in a baseline hazard function
lambda zero and the impacts all of the
features like promo channel but after
showed you any other features that you
can think about that we might put into
this world customers in our dogs are
encoded as this kind of like constant
term on the side which is you know has a
constant impact on the hazard over time
and so there's a few as a little gotcha
there so again it's the most well used
one but the fact that the impacts that
you're having a constant over time you
know might not be true and there's kind
of quite a lot of factors that you could
think about putting in here which would
violate this assumption something like
and I do know the total amount of like
refund you've had over time for instance
that would bury so the quantity would
vary and then have like a varying impact
on the survival over time so it might
not be a sensible choice just to throw
into the Cox model and but then
obviously there's a lot of things that
are you know constant over time which we
know about you from side up in the
consultation of standing good so these
are the type of features that we want to
use in the model like this
so yeah essentially everything we know
about you when you sign up about your
dog about you you know like where you
came from with you read your first email
those kind of things
and also some stuff that you've done in
trial that's kind of but things that we
can take into account before we start
these four we start modeling you and
your lifetime value in housing how long
we think you're going to be a customer
so yeah a little bit on the future
engineering then because I feel like
it's not a date your folks talk and let
me talk a bit about future engineer but
and we've got a lot of categorical data
so particularly stuff like breed oh it's
kind of high cardinality categorical
data so we've got a couple of options
about how we can encode this so kind of
a standard one hot entertaining approach
where you just turn it into like n or n
minus one binary features based on all
the breeds and this would be great for X
if you remember how our how our Cox
model looks it means we'd have a
coefficient attached to every single
breathe so you'd get really good clarity
on how the difference between all of the
levels of your you know between all four
kateri relate to each other which is
quite cool but you're going to end up
with a massive data set obviously you've
got the curse of dimensionality most
likely this isn't going to be the best
way to get a really really accurate
result out of your model so another one
which I tend to use is basically keep as
one feature by the sign at a sensible
ordering because again we're in the
world of essentially a linear model here
I can't just label them 1 2 3 4 that
kind of doesn't make any intrinsic sense
instead what I do is label them by like
the sort of the median time that that
breed has been active which I get from
the Kepler might have better processed
before where we can you know work out
the average time the expected time that
each breed is going to be a customer and
then we and then we feed the model this
instead of the actual breed or some of
the labeling and that gives us you know
it doesn't give a sparse date oh and it
also gives us a sensible ordering which
is like a little bit better and a little
bit more powerful than just linear
ordering like that well I guess the
downside is you don't get the nice
interaction you can't really as clearly
see the relationship between all the
different breeds you just see breeders
one feature and all right so it's saying
if we do the COTS proportional housing
model and we
fits it in a relatively simple way and
then if and then the summary result we
get would look something like this so
here we have down the side just a few of
the features that we put into it and and
then you can read off the coefficient
the exponent of the coefficient which is
ultimately the thing that you're going
to be multiplying your houses rate by so
this is the this is the quantity that
really tells you the impact that this
feature has and then how confident the
model was that it managed to find the
right fit for this particular feature so
you can see second one down email
engagement factor it's got an exponent
of point six three and so the exponent
the further away it is from one their
bigger the effect that this that this
coefficients going to have on the
survival function and the lower their
coefficient it means it reduces the air
hazard rate and so therefore I expect
you to be a customer for longer that
makes sense so for an email engagement
of point six three there how you score
on this email factor this is actually
quite a strong indicator that you're you
know you have quite a reduced hazard
rate and so I think it you're going to
be a customer for much longer and then
compared to if you had life for quite a
low score on that and you can see the
top one is extreme food amount like so
it was but yeah about kind of how much
we're giving you each month and it's
pretty close to one which means it has
basically no impacts and also the model
couldn't really reliably find where this
parameter lived it was somewhere very
close to one either side so in reality
we just want to ditch this from the
model because it's not really telling us
that much and it's kind of just noise
and cool so that's how we make the model
how do we know how good it is so we do
this by something called the concordance
index and what it's essentially doing is
it kind of measuring the ordered pairs
and how well that you'd managed to order
each possible pair in your data set so
and say we just put all of our and that
all of the predictions for the expected
time that would get people going to be a
customer
the line so they'll be obviously greater
than zero just really like this and say
we had two dogs Mowgli who was down here
and mr. patch here both office dogs by
the way and and so let's be how they
like how the model managed to
successfully order these guys
so if Mowgli was active for twelve
months and mr. patch has been active 18
months for simplicity we'll say that
they're both now canceled customers and
and if my model predicted that mr. patch
will be active for longer and then
correct I get one point for that pair if
it predicted Mowgli would be active for
longer I get nothing and then there's
kind of like a normalized and basically
success score of how many ordered pairs
we got right and then the scoring kind
of works the same way as like a area run
to the curve score it's in reality
somewhere between 0.5 and 1 not point 5
would be the same as if we just you know
completely randomly put everything on
the board one would be a perfect
ordering of everybody in the path they
were obviously the closer to 1 the more
accurate that your model is cool and
that's how we make the model and cut
sporting house model that's how we
measure it and then here I've just
dumped out like a random 1% or so with
pets that I was testing this on and
these are all their predictions for the
survival curves so you can see a couple
of things in here one none of the lines
are intersecting which is good again
this comes from our proportional
assumption because the the shape of the
curve is given by your baseline hazard
function and how that you know shifted
up or down this relative to the features
that I put in all of the input data
about you and then obviously we can read
off what happy customer looks like we
can read off what not happy customer
looks like and then obviously one this
gives us a prediction for you and my
expected you know have now an
expectation for how long I think you're
going to be a customer and also we can
kind of start to see what is it that
makes a happy customer of tails and what
is it the you know where are people not
really engaging with our service and
then obviously we can use that to try
and improve retention and improve the
offering for everybody as well as
getting a better understanding of a
retention and lifetime value
so that's kind of that's all I've got to
say so as I said before we are hiring
we've currently got a position for a
data scientist a full stack web
developer sorry a full site developer
and the web developer so if you like
Python data science or dogs and then
here's my email and there's our careers
page so check us out
[Applause]
I can have to shout yeah yes yeah and in
fact actually um one of the yeah exactly
that which I guess well I hadn't really
thought about when I built this it seems
to be I was very much in the head of
just trying to get something which we
could plug into a lifetime value model
but yet in fact the combination of
features that we found from here in the
characteristics turn out to be when you
combine them into kind of a survival
prediction like super predictive in
other attention scenarios so we're kind
of using this very much as an input so
yeah you could have like essentially a
something that doesn't change like from
when someone starts a kind of predicted
time that they're going to be active in
loads and loads of attention scenarios
that with different models that were
doing this does also turn out to be
really good which was a nice bonus great
question and kind of we thought of
skirting it a bit at the moment because
there we're still we're you know we're
only like three four years old as a
company but yeah so I think one of the
things we think about is we've been
lifetime value very much as the customer
in the assumption that you know if
you're if you're a you as a dog owner is
a customer of tails and unfortunately
your dog does die and if you get a new
dog we'd like to think that you can also
come back to tails but it's it's an
excellent point which we haven't got a
smart answer in exactly how we're going
to work out that but yeah it's something
we need to think about just yet
oh that's very specific yeah oh yeah so
what was the best bit oh yes so for the
first one there's a few there's a blend
of a few things so if you you know it's
a subscription so you can pause or
cancel your subscription so that's kind
of obviously a signal that you don't
want the food but we usually we define
it as the time after you paused and or
cancel them been inactive for
sufficiently long so that we don't think
that you've got food at home because
some people will just do that as part of
their daily you know regular management
of subscription they don't like having
stuff active and and yeah if that makes
that answer your question there yeah and
the the kinks are essentially when we
build people so this is these are all
the times effectively because you know
you're more likely to do something when
we remind you that we exist and that we
would like some money so we yes so we
weekly actually how it works in
production is we essentially we use we
kind of use the life the survival
analysis step to come up with like great
segments like customer segmentation
essentially and the you know the types
of customers that we have and then we
kind of use those to sort of like model
retention of those guys separately so
there's sort of a level of abstraction
so weekly and when we update the weekly
assumptions on the customer segments and
every week and then this is kind of
every couple of months or so when we
think that it might have changed how I
segmenting people basically yeah
so I think I got the first bit and kind
of I guess it depends on how you do it
if you have like and I guess yeah
but also we it didn't matter in that we
kind of just cared how much how much
breed was a factor overall rather than
like you know again because we're kind
of using it to sort of understand the
characteristics rather than like getting
a reliable prediction unlike the actual
estimate of days so and I think I'm I
think I was happy with the fact that
there's a little bit of encoding bias in
there that license but it's a good point
that's of data and so in there well I
used it in as much as like in the Copts
model it will take into account
basically yes so we'd label essentially
at the point where we aren't definitely
sure that you're not a customer anymore
which is either that you're still active
or that you have food sufficiently
recently that we know that you are still
possible that you're feeding your dog
tails yes so we've basically encode that
into that as part of the fit so the
model does take into account yeah
exactly
yes so you have how it actually works in
life lenses you can yet you pass it a
censorship column which is binary one if
the data censored zero otherwise yeah so
um we I suppose with the lifetime value
kind of access like an average over the
point so essentially that at the moment
we don't we kind of in the way we use it
we look at the lifetime value of the
people that are still active but if
you're not active you still kind of
intrinsically have a value so that we
don't basically run into the issues
where you know your like your value is
zero and then the next day if you come
back your value it's like 100 pounds
over however long so it's sort of
because we kind of take the lifetime
value view is very much like from the
day that you start paying looking
forwards like how long you know how much
value you think you're going to do that
and it's kind of like an average
everybody who would like you at the time
and so we just sort of kind of yeah we
basically just we still give you value
but we just kind of ignore you if you're
not currently active
yep so I suppose I guess we kind of do
it from like I mean yeah it's a good
point and I also kind of had this
worried but I think and I don't know if
anyone else knows of a way and directly
from survival analysis that a different
interpretation of what I'm about to say
but yeah again I guess because
essentially we're like we're essentially
segmenting you by your position in like
this ordering and then we'll then kind
of model your attention separately using
like you know different analysis that we
have so that's kind of how we we get the
segment's and then we trace that back to
like actually what you did which is sort
of how we overcome that
and yeah well I suppose essentially well
we I guess we kind of do that for the
lifetime value because your
profitability is yeah I mean the biggest
the two biggest drivers I guess with the
profitability is where the overall value
is like essentially profitability by
each order in the retention so we do
have you know it's not there's not a
perfect correlation between our highest
retain customers and our you know most
value driving customers because of the
order interaction within there is that
what you mean
[Applause]